we're not scripted
joy behar gets candid about when she was
fired from the view it was a big deal at
the time since joy had been on the
series since it debuted in 1997.
i remember when we started the show and
i said to barbara you know barbara we're
going to get old on this show and she
said you're going to get old anyway fans
will recall the comedian parted ways
with the long running daytime talk show
in 2013. i was summarily dismissed
and looking back it may have been a
blessing in disguise in a new interview
with time joyce says i was glad to be
fired she explains quote i basically was
sick of the show at that point for some
reason i don't even remember why i was a
doctor for the show
but longtime viewers might have some
theories remember those legendary
showdowns with former view co-host
elizabeth hasselbeck confidence is what
it is okay she's a court of confidence
but at least we do know why she was
excited to come back joy laid it out for
e.t when she returned to the series two
years later it's gonna be a new ride
it's just a new ride it's a different
ride it's not the same people i worked
with before so it's like a whole new job
the view is one of those places where
you wanna you wanna sort of share your
personal life but there's a there's a
limit to what i will say you know i've
had a lot of therapy and that's what you
need at the view
i am i'm confident about it because i
get along with people
and you know what it's just television
let's not get carried away here
and years later joy gave us a pretty
good recap of what went down i was
summarily dismissed and then i was they
begged me to come back and here i am
fast forward to 2022 joyce helping the
view celebrate 25 years of hot topics i
like the audience i like the camaraderie
i like the fun of it as she tells it the
show is at its best when everyone comes
ready to debate it's like a friendly
argument is a great thing on the show
you know people who disagree with each
other i always used to say in the
meetings in the morning
don't pick topics where we all agree
[Music]